bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum which means peace be unto you
welcome to another episode of the Dean
show you want to know about Islam you've
come to the right place you want to know
about Muslims you've come to the source
now today we're going to be discussing a
very very important topic it's something
that if we understand properly we will
live a better life we will live a
complete life it is the concept of
salvation we're going to be talking
about something that some of you are
familiar with some of you might even
believe now this might be sensitive to
some people so we apologize our
intention is not to upset anybody or
hurt anybody's feelings our next guest
is going to be talking about the
salvation that some people believe that
someone else paid the price for your
sins let's see what he has to say our
next guest said tight is dr. Lawrence
Brown right back on the Dean show love
there's only one but Muhammad is His
Messenger of love that you know how
ah ha there's only one bed and Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice so
all the chrome aleykum Selam tada how
are you dr. Brown I'll hamdullah good
thank you for being with us some of our
audience already already are familiar
with you we've been a few shows in the
past and I'm very happy excited that
you're back again good to be here all
right we want to talk about we can get
straight to the topic some people they
have conveniently or some people have
just blindly or some people have
sincerely accepted the idea the belief
that someone else has paid the price for
their sins we want to discuss this we
want your ideas and we want your opinion
on this okay you know let me begin by
saying that religious discussion is
always a little bit sensitive and it's
not our intention to hurt anybody's
feelings rather our intention is just to
get to the root of the matter we were
talking earlier about on one of our
earlier episodes about how I became
Muslim basically was my path through
Christianity or exactly what my path was
and I've voiced some of my concerns
about Christianity in that episode the
reason why I i myself was not able to
accept the tenants of christian faith
one of the reasons was that christian
faith hinges off of the concept of the
atonement the concept that jesus christ
died for our sins i always had trouble
with that concept i never understood how
Jesus Christ or anybody could die for
anybody else's sins and so that's
basically what we decided together to
talk about on this show I think the the
beginning point that I would make is
that the concept of the atonement is one
of the most simplistic but beautiful
formulas
that exists for religious salvation I'm
the concept that if you believe in Jesus
Christ and you'd believe that he died
for your sins then that is sufficient
for redemption that is sufficient for
salvation you will have your place in
paradise and I mean I have to say sounds
good to me what do you think we be a
fool not to accept it and that's kind of
my point I mean my point is if it were
true and that's the big if if it were
true we would all be fools not for
accepting it it would be the easiest
thing just to say where do I sign on the
bottom line and give me my key to
paradise so first of all we have to
validate the concept we have to ask
ourselves is it true did Jesus Christ
died for our sins and i'd say if we're
going to if we're going to analyze that
concept first thing we have to do is ask
the witnesses I mean let's ask the
people who were there and who saw it
okay let's ask the Bible let's ask the
Gospels but there's a problem there if
we're going to look at Matthew Mark Luke
and John those are what what has regard
what are regarded as the biblical
witnesses however the big problem there
is Matthew Mark and Luke Luke and John
we're not written by Matthew Mark luton
Luke and John this is a very little
known fact but the fact of the matter is
that all four Gospels were anonymous
none of them are signed none of them
bury the name of the author they were
given those names out of convenience now
i'm going to go sent to some notes here
because I want to get this letter
perfect and I'm going to read you
something a statement by Graham Stenton
one of one of the greatest scholars of
our time on the New Testament and he
wrote the Gospels unlike most
greco-roman writings are anonymous the
familiar headings which give the name of
an author the Gospel according to were
not part of the original manuscripts for
they were added only
early in the 2nd century ad it in the
2nd century who added them who added
those names to the Gospels who we don't
know who wrote them well believe it or
not who added them we don't know that
either now I don't mean to get real
picky here but if I were to give anybody
out there a book of guidance on anything
a book of guidance on car repair a book
of guidance on astrophysics something
that's going to impact your life
something that you want to know the
authority of first question in your mind
is going to be what I mean it's going to
be who wrote this right and yet here
we're being told that the Gospels the
four Gospels all four Gospels of the
Bible are anonymous I had a problem with
that and I think a lot of other people
do but I tell you what let's just forget
all that and why not because most people
forget all that anyway for the last
2,000 years we've had sort of this
syndrome of trying to push that aside so
let's just for the sake of discussion
put that aside and instead let's just
look at the scriptural Authority again
I'm going to read to you the
interpreters dictionary of the Bible the
interpreters dictionary of the Bible now
this is obviously a Christian work
states it is safe to say that there is
not one sentence in the New Testament in
which the manuscript tradition is wholly
uniform not one sentence Bart Dearman
stated it in terms that I think are
perhaps a little bit easier for us to
get our our grasp upon he said quote
possibly it is easiest to put the matter
in comparative terms there are more
differences in our manuscripts than
there are words and then in the New
Testament there are more differences in
our manuscripts than there are words in
the New Testament which really gives me
a very good you know sound feeling about
the Bible
no and I would just say it shouldn't
shouldn't give anybody a feeling of
comfort about the work we've talked
about the fact that you know the Gospels
were anonymous many of the other books
were anonymous and now we're hearing
that there are more differences in the
manuscripts than there are words in the
New Testament so I don't mean to cut you
off tell me so just to get this straight
you're telling us that we don't know who
actually wrote these books that Jesus
obviously didn't write it we don't have
the Gospel according to Jesus and many
people are under the assumption that
these were his companions these were
people that live with him is this
correctly exhaust is not true and these
are the references that people can go
check so there you're not making this up
according to exactly and by the way
everything that I read you everything
that I tell you you can find in my
articles and in my books which will come
back to but the point is that if we look
to the Gospels Matthew Mark Luke and
John we first have to understand we're
not reading Matthew Mark Luke and John
we're reading anonymous anonymous
anonymous anonymous okay we don't know
who wrote them and there are tremendous
differences between them let me give you
an example okay I mean let's say that
you pick up a book of mathematics and on
page one it says one plus one is two and
on page 10 it says one plus one is three
you know there's a problem right big
problem yeah you're probably going to
ditch that book pretty fast well if
we're holding the Bible up as being a
book of revelation from God we have to
expect that there is not a single error
within the Bible but let me just read
some things to you for example the Bible
tells us what Jesus wore what he drank
and what he said right yes and no some
people say one thing others say another
for example in Matthew 27 28 the Roman
soldiers dressed Jesus in a scarlet robe
however in John 1919 too it says that
the rope was purple Matthew 27 34 says
the wrong
men gave Romans gave Jesus sour wine
mixed with gall in Matthew 1523 it was
mixed with myrrh Matthew 15 25 Jesus was
crucified before the third hour John
1914 through 15 says about the sixth
hour Luke 2346 says Jesus's last words
were father into your hands I commit my
spirit beautiful words only problem is
in John 1930 it records Jesus's last
words as it is finished now I'll say
just kind of a whimsical story here I
bet I picked up a book a little while
ago called famous last words yes right
and it recorded people's famous with
last words throughout history one of the
one of the funniest ones won the mutton
the one I liked the most was this
general at Battle of spotsylvania during
the Civil War ok one of his aides was
telling him not to be lifting his head
up of over a parapet because it was not
cautious it was dangerous his famous fat
last words were ah they couldn't hit an
elephant at this dist and that was the
end they couldn't hit an elephant at
this disk he couldn't even finish his
sentence he got killed famous last words
what's my point my point is that
followers of famous people hang on to
their words all right and when a person
is dying they hang on to the words even
more closely because everybody is
looking to quote your famous last words
you know what and they're looking
they're looking for the answer like that
famous question what's the answer and
the dying person said what's the
question but the point is they got the
quote right and here in the Bible we
have two Gospels written by people we
don't know but let's say we trust them
they both say different things one says
the last words were Jesus's last words
were it is finished the other into your
hands I commend my spirit so we have to
ask ourselves is this
is this something that we would trust
now you know when we're talking about
the atonement what the what does this
all come down to it all comes down to
the crucifixion right yeah question of
did Jesus died for our sins well let's
take that a step further did Jesus die
at all if we look at the biblical
accounts of what happened before and
after the alleged crucifixion we have to
remember in the Garden of Gethsemane
according to the Bible all of the
disciples deserted deserted Jesus and
fled now if all of the disciples
deserted him and fled who's there at his
trial who is there at his persecution
who is there at his crucifixion we don't
know we don't know who is there we don't
know who he wrote about it we don't know
the authority of what we have in our
hands what we do know is this following
the alleged crucifixion who went to the
tomb according to Matthew Mary Magdalene
and the other marriage according to mark
Mary Magdalene according to Luke the
women who had come with him from Galilee
according to John Mary Magdalene why did
they go to the tomb Matthew to see the
tomb mark they brought spices Luke they
brought spices and John no reason was
there an earthquake Matthew yes Mark
Luke John no mention did an angel
descend Matthew yes Mark Luke John no
mention wait a minute I have a problem
we're talking about an earthquake and an
angel descending we're not talking about
something as simple as Jesus riding the
donkey all of the Gospels agree Jesus
rode the donkey which is pretty high on
the who cares list who cares if he wrote
the doggy but they all agree he wrote
the donkey but we have three Gospels who
failed to mention an angel descending
and an earthquake I mean can you imagine
three newspapers recording a historical
event and one of the mentions in angel
one of the mentions an earthquake and
three dome I'm I'm only pointing out
that we have a reason to
have suspicions about the account who
rolled back the stone Matthew the angel
Mark Luke and John unknown who is at the
tomb Matthew an angel mark a young man
Luke two men John two angels where were
they Matthew the angel was sitting at
the stone outside the tomb mark young
man the young man was in the tomb
sitting on the right side Luke the two
men were inside the tomb standing beside
them and John the two angels were quote
sitting one at the head the other at the
foot were the body of Jesus had lain by
whom and where was Jesus first scene
when he was allegedly resurrected
Matthew Mary Magdalene and the other
Mary on the road to tell his disciples
mark Mary Magdalene only Luke to the
disciples John Mary Magdalene outside
the tomb different people different
places different times and we're told to
believe it so my point is that we have
to begin by questioning the scriptural
authority to begin with if there were
four stories that we knew who they were
written by and they all they all backed
each other up detail for detail we would
have a foundation upon which we could
trust this but we have four Gospels
anonymously written conflicting with one
another on huge details and were asked
to believe it dr. Brown I want to be
fair for the the person who you know he
says will hold on you have this is an
event that's one of the the most
documented in history historians like
Josephus and others who have documented
this as an event that did take place how
do you respond well first of all I mean
we have to remember that in the Islamic
tradition we do not disagree about a
crucifix Chris
having happened okay in the Islamic
tradition a crucifixion did happen but
Muslims believe that Jesus Christ was
not the one who was crucified now I have
to make a point here a little known fact
is that early Christians were divided on
this issue many early Christians did not
also did not believe that Jesus Christ
was because this is effect this is a
fact that there was a big controversy a
word if I everyone didn't just believe
this they were divided okay early
Christians had different concepts about
this and some of the sex which which
denied the crucifixion were huge and
their reasons for denying it were sound
as well for example Jesus Christ prayed
to be saved from the from the
crucifixion at the same time in the
Bible we're told that that God heard his
prayers because he was a righteous man
know what does hurt his prayers mean
does that mean heard his prayers and
then refused them no it means heard his
prayers and accepted them otherwise it
wouldn't make any sense it would be like
saying God heard his prayers and denied
him because he was a righteous man but
doesn't that wouldn't make any sense so
you know many many early Christians they
did not believe that Jesus Christ had
been crucified they believed that he was
raised up and the Islamic belief is that
another was substituted in this place
but it was made to appear to the people
that it was Jesus Christ who was
substituted the vote is out but the most
popular opinion is that it was Judas
Iscariot yeah he was the one who was
deserving punishment he was he was the
traitor to God's prophet and and the
Islamic belief is that God altered his
features or the perception of the people
to believe that he was Jesus Christ he
was crucified in place of Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ Himself was raised up until
the time that he will return
dr. Brown tell me is there any explicit
statement that Jesus peace be upon him
ever said that I am coming to die for
the sins of the world this is a serious
matter I just want to know the one that
we loved Jesus did he ever say that he's
gonna believe it him and you'll be saved
from all these sins and yeah I'm dying
for your sins and put it on my back I'll
carry it for you well I call it the
Jesus gold card no I mean first of all
no and you have to ask yourself why
because the purpose that were said no
right not at all no you know he never
said he was going to die for the sins of
mankind as a matter of fact he said many
things that would indicate that he
wasn't going to okay again Jesus Christ
was a was a Orthodox Jew he taught the
the Jewish the Mosaic law he come he
came saying do not think that I have
come to destroy the law I have not come
but to fulfill and he even elaborated he
said until heaven and earth shall pass
not one job not one tittle of the law
shall be destroyed until all is
fulfilled see you know the the point is
that that he was following Mosaic law
and what did Mosaic law teach Mosaic law
taught that the father shall not bear
the iniquity of the Sun and the Sun
shall not bear the iniquity of the
Father that makes sense okay makes sense
and there's evidence for it right so
basically what Jesus Christ was teaching
was against the even against the concept
of original sin because how can the sun
bear the iniquity of Adam if he doesn't
even bear the iniquity of his father
mm-hmm okay and you have another example
when when the children were gathering
around Jesus he said do not forbid them
for of thine is the kingdom of heaven
these were children they you know if
they had original sin upon them he
wouldn't be able to say of thine is the
kingdom of heaven because they would be
stained by original sin mm-hmm what what
he was saying is contrary to what we are
being told by the church his companions
now those who knew him the best those
who were around
him they witnessed his teachings did
they ever preach this that Jesus died
for the sins of the world no the way
that the concept grew was that Jesus
Christ himself taught accountability I
mean if you if you read the if you read
a red letter bible the bible that shows
you all of the the actual recorded words
of jesus in red you will find that all
that he taught was to keep the law and
he could condemned he condemned anybody
who practiced lawlessness with regard to
salvation he taught that if you want the
kingdom of heaven i bade the loss okay
Paul came along and abolished the laws
and established the concept of of just
the atonement as established the concept
of justification by faith so these were
the this is part of the conflict between
the teachings of Jesus which was the law
of the kingdom of God and the teachings
of Paul which abolished that mm-hmm
let's bring it back to the one who was
in charge of everything who's running
maintaining sustaining this universe did
he ever send a messenger some of the
greatest message we know Abraham Noah
Moses we discussed what Jesus said in
the last and final messenger prophet
muhammad peace be upon them all did any
of them at any time preach teach
anything of this that we're talking
about no but i will tell you what what
did happen every every prophet taught
the oneness of God the the absolute
necessity of keeping his law and
personal accountability however in every
instance I know of at some point in time
following the period of Revelation the
people found this a little bit too
difficult a little bit too confining
and you found some charismatic leader
who would come along and give the people
what they need it basically an easier
path the only problem is that the
question arises is this are these
promises going to be there when those
people present themselves on the day of
judgment look we're being told to accept
the concept of original sin that we bear
the stain of the sins of Adam even
though Jesus Christ Himself endorsed the
the teaching that no son will bear the
iniquity of the Father okay at the same
time we are told that Jesus died for our
sins and yet in i'm just going to quote
again I know you hate this but Hosea 66
according to God quote I desert I desire
mercy and not sacrifice I desire mercy
and not sacrifice dezod and not
sacrifice and then here we're being told
but God sacrificed his only begotten
child wait a minute you then turn around
and ask well why has anybody I'm sure
we've all questioned this at some time
Why ask why did God have to sacrifice
his quote as according to them the you
know Trinitarian faith his quote only
begotten Son why the answer comes back
because God needed an atoning sacrifice
I just have to say that flies in the
face of reason it goes against what
Muslims believe because of one word need
the word need God needed a sacrifice we
we as human beings we need we need
things God doesn't need anything he may
have things that he wants but he would
like to see us be good people he would
like to see a servant worshippin but he
doesn't need there is nothing that we
can do there's nothing that week we can
give God that he couldn't have
by his own volition so then you ask well
well why couldn't God have forgiven us
without a sacrifice is God not big
enough to do that I guess it comes down
to your concept of God and each person
has to just ask themselves what makes
what makes sense does it doesn't make
more sense to trust anonymous gossip
Gospels which conflict in their stories
conflict in their evidence etc etc or
does it make more sense to follow the
you know the train of logic that I'm
that I'm talking about I mean I just to
go back we wouldn't accept someone
trying to bring a case forward in court
and there's no witnesses that we can
examine so this is just illogical that
we would accept something and blindly
believe it even though we don't know
what the witness are we covered that
point we're almost running out of time I
want to now address this issue of true
salvation because some people who are
sincere and that's who we're reaching
out to we want the sincere people who
have questioned this and that's all they
knew but they know that you know what
this doesn't make sense i'm not going to
be responsible for something someone did
you know adam pick the apple and now
it's on me and i got to force myself to
believe something that just does not
make sense so tell us tell the viewers
what is the correct concept for
salvation talk to us well you know to
begin with i would say that whenever you
see something that doesn't make sense
you have to run from it I do have to
what make one final point that is that
we're told that the first step to
salvation in Christianity is to
recognize that the atoning sacrifice of
Jesus Christ ok this is the theme of
this talk right this involves two things
involves the the concept of original sin
and the atoning sacrifice in one case
we're told that it doesn't matter if you
believe in the other case we're told it
only matters if you believe let me give
you an example
are we as all human beings according to
Christianity do we all have the stain of
original sin upon us the answer is yes
whether you believe or not whether you
believe or not you you're affected by
original sin ok can we achieve salvation
just through the atoning sacrifice of
Jesus even if we don't believe in it no
you have to believe it if you believe in
it then you'll be saved if you don't
believe it in you won't be safe wait a
minute was it an atoning sacrifice or
not if it was an atoning sacrifice it
doesn't matter whether you believe or
not if it wasn't an atoning sacrifice it
doesn't matter either way to come back
to the question what is true salvation
you know I just think I think everybody
out there who has a sound mind and a
sound heart and who hasn't been
brainwashed to believe something else
knows the answer to that true salvation
is to turn to your Creator with an open
heart to repent for your sins to declare
true belief and then to walk in the path
of the servitude and worship of him as
he prescribes for us that is true
salvation and that you just have got to
take it in those steps I mean number one
you have to recognize him not as other
people tell you to recognize him but as
he actually is as one one God one
creator you have to you have to repent
for the sins that you have made through
a priest through a minister through an
imam know through your heart directly to
your God ok because it's between you and
him there's no intermediary and then you
have to declare true faith you have to
declare if you're sincere you have to
declare that you will accept his
religion and adhere to it and that's
what it takes dr. Brown we can go on and
on and people can you have a chapter
about the crucifixion in miss Cotter and
Miss got it and you can visit dr. Brown
at level truth calm
all truths calm and in the misguided he
has a whole chapter on the crucifixion
and he's got a ton of other great stuff
in here you can look into his books and
we hope in sha Allah to have you back
again hope to be here again thanks
thanks very much thank you very much and
I like to thank everyone for sitting
through another episode of the Dean show
now just to recap as our guest dr. Brown
had mentioned Jesus peace be upon him he
never taught he never taught this
concept that he came to die for your
sins his companions never taught this
and most of all the one who has the
attribute of being the just the creator
of the heavens and the earth he didn't
attach the stigma to you you were born
in original goodness if you make a
mistake we all do with human beings turn
to the crater alone and ask him to
forgive you he is the most forgiving the
most loving he will forgive you now with
that said we're going to cut out and
we'll see you next time on another
episode of the Dean show until then
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you the
dvds for Dawa is Allah has set in the
car honest with a now 16 125 will do
elasa be laid up pick up the hikmah to
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom beautiful preaching and reason
with them in ways that are best and this
is a great opportunity for you to take
up the obligation take up the call as
allah has told you to do and share this
beautiful message with the world islam
submission to the one god let's see what
everyone's talking about if you find one
contradiction it can't be from God in
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring guide is why I will never
give up spending this message hope there
you take that necessary step you don't
know if you're gonna live till tomorrow
so you gotta find that urgency to do the
right thing right now if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of his name you cannot
be a Muslim is attended our faith to its
cold ain't lay everybody sleeping I
arise and asked a lot of thinking me
Omar you see all are you know all the
sins I do I turn to you to figure my sin
tomorrow I'm you sinful slave you're my
love alone I'm the one runs away oh the
guide me